we have the million we have the number
seven million three hundred forty-six
thousand five hundred and twenty-one and
30 mm and what I want to think about is
if I look at the same digit in two
different places in particular I'm going
to look at the digit 3 here and the
digit 3 here how much more value does
this left 3 represent than this right 3
in order to think about that we have to
think about place value so let's write
down all the place values so this right
over here this is the ones place and we
could move to the right and as we move
to the right and place values each place
represents one tenth of the place before
it or you could divide by ten as we're
moving to the right so this is the ones
place this is divided by ten this is the
one tenths place or the tenths place
divided by 10 again this is the
hundredths place divided by 10 again
this is the thousandths place and that s
I'm just saying to be plural hundredths
thousandths now if we go to the left now
each place represents a factor of 10
more so this is one's multiplied by 10
this is the tens place this is the
hundreds place this is the thousands
thousands place this is the ten
thousands place I would have to write a
little bit smaller this is the hundred
thousands place and then the seven is in
the millions place millions millions
place so what is this number what is
this 3 represent what's in the hundred
thousands place it literally represents
three hundred thousands three hundred
thousands or you could say three hundred
thousand three hundred thousand three
followed by five zeros now what does
this three represent it's in the
hundredths place it literally represents
three hundredths it represents three
times one over a hundred which is the
same thing as three which is equal to
three over let me do the three in that
purple color which is the same thing as
three over a hundred which is the same
thing as three over hundred which is the
same
which is the same thing 0.03 0.03 these
are all equivalent statements now let's
try to answer our original question how
much larger is this 3 then that 3 there
well one way to think about it is how
much would you have to multiply this 3
by to get to this 3 over here well one
way to think about it is to look
directly at place value so we got to
multiply by 10 every time we multiply by
2 every time we multiply by 10 that's
equivalent to thinking about shifting it
to one place to the left so we would
have to multiply by 10 one two three
four five six seven times so multiplying
by 10 seven times let me write this down
so this multiplied by ten seven times
should be equal to this let me rewrite
this 300,000 should be equal to should
be equal to 3 over 100 let me write it
the same way 3 over 100 3 over 100
multiplied by 10 seven times so times 10
times 10 times 10 times 10 times 10
let's see that's five times times 10
times 10 now multiplying by some by 10
seven times is the same thing as
multiplying by one followed by seven
zeroes every time you multiply by 10
you're going to get another zero here so
this is the same thing as 3 over 100 3
over 100 times times one followed by one
two three four five six seven zeroes so
this is literally 3 over 100 times 10
million so let's see if this actually is
the case is this actually equal does
this actually equal 300,000 300,000 well
if you if you divide 10 million by 100
well you could dividing 10 million by a
hundred or I guess you could say in the
numerator you have 10 million in the
denominator you have 100 if
you just multiply it like this if you
view this as 3 over 100 times 10 million
over 1
well you divide the numerator by 100
you're going to get rid of two of these
zeros divide the denominator by 100
you're going to get rid of this 100 here
and so you're going to be left with 3
times and we've got to be careful with
the commas here because since I removed
two zeros the commas are going to be
different it's going to be three times
we put our commas in the right place so
just like that so this simplifies this
simplified to three times 100,000 which
is indeed 300,000 so it did work out
shifting the three one two three four
five six seven decimal places makes that
three worth one followed by seven zeroes
more or it essentially makes that three
worth 10 million more so this 3 is
represents 10 million times the value of
this 3 let me write down the numbers so
this 3 is 10 million 10 million 10
million times the value of that 3